is a 30-year mortgage
really that much different from a
15-year mortgage you bet it is let's
take a look at the math behind both a
thirty-year and a 15-year and then you
can decide if it's really that big a
deal
a 30-year mortgage on a two hundred and
twenty five thousand dollar home with
six percent interest has a payment of
1349 now on a 15-year mortgage the
payments would be eighteen ninety-nine
that's a five hundred and fifty dollar
difference doesn't really seem like that
much right wrong when you pay 1349 a
month for thirty years at 6% you're
actually paying four hundred and eighty
five thousand dollars for your two
hundred and twenty five thousand dollar
home now let's do the math for a 15-year
mortgage on that same house a monthly
payment of eighteen ninety nine for 15
years at the same interest rate is a
total of three hundred and forty-one
thousand dollars for the home so when
you do a 15-year mortgage you save
yourself a hundred and forty four
thousand dollars did you get that by
going with a 15-year instead of a
30-year mortgage you saved yourself a
hundred and forty four thousand dollars
it's a lot of money and you end up
saving yourself about fifteen extra
years of bondage still aren't convinced
then let's take another look say you
still have that same home with the same
payment amount now fast forward ten
years the two hundred and twenty five
thousand dollar loan on a 15-year note
is paid down to about ninety eight
thousand dollars after ten years on the
30-year mortgage that house is paid down
to about a hundred and eighty eight
thousand so what does that mean it means
that if you got a 30-year mortgage
you've paid almost a hundred and sixty
two thousand dollars but you've really
only knocked 36 thousand off the loan
let me put it another way over the past
ten years you've given the bank a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars and
if you're thinking about getting a
30-year mortgage and paying it off in
fifteen think again vacations prom
dresses home improvements something else
will always seem more important but you
know the cool thing about a 15-year
mortgage it always pays off in fifteen
years or less
the bottom line is this if you think
you're getting a better deal with a
30-year mortgage just because you're
saving a few hundred bucks a month
you're only thinking short-term if you
open your eyes a little bit and start
thinking long-term you'll see that
you're literally throwing away hundreds
of thousands of dollars don't sign up
for a 30 year mortgage just because
everyone else is hey everyone else is
broke